here's the difference between american
men and
european or latin american middle
eastern men the reason why american men
are not really pursuing the way that
they're supposed to is one because
they've been spoiled already if you
don't know this already
latin men
european men and middle eastern men all
have one thing in common they're
actually men they pursue women and they
are very persistent they're consistent
and they essentially do all of the work
in the pursuit
we've officially
went full circle here
and the only thing left to do is burn in
hell
we went for oh my god 50 shade of gray
is so good to uh don't talk to me back
to oh my god pursue me you're a real man
oh my god
remember we were doing that podcast and
that girl
right in the middle it was like 2018 and
that girl was like yeah but you know
sometimes when we sing
[Music]
sometimes when we say no it means yes
bro
i was like oh [ __ ] you're not the one
and they know how to court women why is
it that they do this right from the jump
because
in their european middle eastern and
latin society women
have not spoiled them the way that women
here have spoiled men women make them
work hard for their time their
availability they require more of men
and that's why these men know that if
they don't know how to pursue and court
a woman accordingly they're not getting
anything no no no it's because feminism
is not as prevalent that's it
that's it the gender roles are very
strong that's it ain't got nothing with
being spoiled or anything like that it's
really just a question of positioning
okay i'm also confused because like
europe is
a big place i'm sure there's a bunch of
european women in the comments right
like right now being like no the [ __ ]
out here are also spoiled uh the men
here ain't doing [ __ ]
all right i got a lot of home girls out
in london all right they be telling me
dudes out there hella lazy all right to
all my english brothers
my english brothers all right apparently
you guys got a terrible rep because the
women out there in england be talking
[ __ ] about you all the time so um i
don't know what she's talking about uh
the ladies in france don't have good
things to say about the men over there
they don't and i can keep going down the
list about the european country so they
really don't so yeah yeah yeah i think
you know i think this is this is like
those things where because you live
somewhere you're convinced it's the
worst place
and you can miss that the world yeah
yeah but you don't feel like oh my god
men in miami oh my god women in new york
oh my god the guys in la are all mexican
it's like chill okay you live on 33rd
street that's the people on 33rd street
people always be [ __ ] about the
place they live on when it comes to
daily market
go ask anybody who's single so you know
what's going on with you in your city
yeah the women in atlanta are my
brothers why are you always [ __ ] the
people in your city oh but if you would
take them at a face value you would
think every city in the world's got the
worst people to date everybody's trash
yeah right so everyone thinks when i
leave i'm gonna find me a man or a woman
somewhere else you don't you don't you
end up with a different problem yeah
again that's another case of you being
trafficked and you're not being stuck in
it uh men are so this and that because
women are late you're lazy
you're lazy you're doing that you're
part of the problem yeah okay i think
it's fascinating that it's like all this
critique about how men are lazy men are
this and that it's like well your
definition of effort is just presenting
yourself and looking good
men got to look good put in the efforts
courts you say the right say financially
invest in the whole thing you just got
to be present and we don't labor and
maybe
maybe you get maybe you get a thing
there's a certain level of arrogance
that's very fascinating it's like
whenever you're a boss you know when you
work a job and your boss your boss is
like you guys are lazy work harder and
you walk in their office and sleep for
three and a half hours and you're like
[ __ ] if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
there and work with us
i'm not even mad
to do that work i'm just saying
don't be ungrateful yeah don't ask me to
do all that labor and then look at me
like oh [ __ ] you supposed to do this
you know what i'm saying and that's not
just true for dating that's true for
relationships as well it's like it's not
because my girl's cooking and cleaning
that i was like yeah you're supposed to
do that
don't forget to be grateful for what the
other person does
like some people just expect it
and then come out hungry that's the [ __ ]
that really irks the [ __ ] out of me
that pisses me off
it's like if i do a kind thing for you
don't be like well as a man you're
supposed to do that appreciate it the
same way women when you guys do things
on your end fellas don't take that [ __ ]
for granted like for me
if somebody cooks me at me or i make
them real like don't be like yay
whatever
really
you get what i'm saying
that's the stuff that will like just
chip away at you so when i see this
stuff and dating it just it makes me
cringe a little bit
yeah you supposed to you are mean
ah imagine being married to someone who
thinks like that he just takes what
you're supposed to do for a claim never
does that couldn't be me
i'm a kind dude like listen to people in
my life no i take care of them but if
you just expect it with a certain level
of arrogance like [ __ ] who raised you
coming to somebody's dinner place the
food's here yeah it's supposed to be
if you don't say thank you appreciate
this beautiful meal you make that's
cringe who raised some of you animals
that kills me about people
it's the entitlement that just makes me
like
yeah i expect a man to approach me i
expect a girl to put out but it doesn't
happen sometimes so what that's toxic by
i say
not toxic when you expect it
this girl i feel like both genders are
now just trying to convince the other
like they're the price yes men you're
the price women you're the price make
sure that they follow your rules man
make sure they follow them so i'm gonna
just i'm gonna back you're just cringing
bro stay in your tower and be the king
of whatever kingdom of loneliness you
are i mean i mean do your thing do your
thing yeah go go go go go go go go to
cuba the thing in the video go to
dominican republic go go go be go be
part of your favorite bachata song guess
what those lyrics he's cheating on you
with your sister okay
listen fidelity latin america
i mean they love jesus but uh
faithfulness
if it's faith in jesus sure if it's
faith in the marriage uh that's a
different question i mean they love
jesus but they love jesus better
listen stop their two favorite pastimes
in latin america are football and
cheating okay
sometimes they do both at the same time
all right there's balls being dribbled
get me
bro
don't sit here like what what you think
what do you think we think in the arab
world faithfulness is a top priority
or keeping your woman happy is
what do you think europe listen a lot of
those countries the traditional gender
roles are very much enforced yes
go to france it's not exactly the most
progressive woman i've ever met in my
life
no
no disrespect i got no beef with it but
it compares to north america they're not
in any way shaped progressive like you
guys are
so you want a different kind of
treatment but you not even you want the
very like traditional role masculine but
you're not the traditional female either
no they're what you're talking about
they want they want to pick and choose
the court and yeah and then after that
go back to make me my food in the south
no you make me my food on the side
silent sandwich
[ __ ] that's what it is really yeah you
can't pick and like it's not cute you
romanticize just one part of the deal
they romanticize always the ones
do it too
you guys will be like yeah imma get me
an eastern european woman because
they're so feminine on this and that
yeah you know what they expect you to
take care of all the bills and take care
of all this stuff and be traditional
dude yourself too you ain't got the
finances bro yeah you make out the money
your passport is cute it just gets the
girl in the country doesn't get her to
stay
you don't want to get with a pissed off
freshman woman yay
you know you talk about the traditional
understand everything it means doesn't
mean she gonna suck your dick every day
like you want her to i think you
misunderstood how this [ __ ] works you
didn't you didn't read the fine prints
no you didn't no
everybody out here romanticizing people
foreign women
brother
have you even been there i've never been
eastern you but i watch a podcast
everybody got their downsides
everybody got their qualities and
everything and stuff yeah i understand
some people are gonna be like yeah i
like better these these sure it is what
it is sure but you got to be able to put
you got to be able to handle the rest
but a lot of people don't know what they
talk about they're going off stereotypes
and what they imagine yeah they actually
don't know the people from that culture
so they don't have a real view of it
they're just out here talking mm-hmm you
know i'm saying i hear dudes talk about
like ethiopian women sometimes bruh you
don't even know what the ladies down
there like you just you don't know what
the cultural heritage is like you don't
know what the religious upbringing how
you saw it
you saw you saw a few pictures you're
like damn and look at she must be so
feminine but i cringed so hard
so hard so in conclusion the reason why
american men are weenies and they don't
know how to pursue women is because
women here have let them get away with
doing the bare minimum
and
that's not okay and that's just a record
scratch by not requiring more of men and
not expecting more of them
and making them work for it you're
essentially making them lazy you're
creating more [ __ ] boys and you're
putting yourself in situations where you
end up being the one pursuing him and
worried about whether he likes you
enough women in these other cultures
they're not ever doing that they let men
come to them
and if they come correct
then maybe you get a date
and that's a maybe you're up for
consideration
department all right you really think
you're some kind of hit
oh you're the thing yeah you got a per
baby you're annoying as [ __ ] okay
you really want people to pursue you
gotta a and yeah you're not the one
you're not you're cute but you're not
the one honey stop they accept non-dates
that are coffee walking
[ __ ] dates so far that girl's gonna
she's gonna give ahead about coffee
dates like the reason why dudes prefer
doing coffee dates a lot of time is to
gauge whether or not the woman's really
there for them or they're really there
for a free meal yeah you know first off
you already expect us to pay for
everything in terms of the courting
process even if then you're telling us
what's acceptable and how much we have
to pay for the experience if you're
there to get to know me for real for
real then what's wrong with the coffee
date we're gonna sit there we're gonna
have a conversation and it's cool but no
no you need you need that little
princess experience you're gonna be
taking out some kind of fancy dinner or
some [ __ ]
y'all gonna wake up alone at 50 and be
like oh my god i went to my years yeah
you had that aren't even requiring much
effort
and they accept very subpar behavior and
they're okay if these guys don't talk to
them for days on end suck at
communication they're totally fine with
that and that's how we've given birth to
the [ __ ] boy and weenies you should
start requiring more of men notice how
the guys that'll come correct will stick
around no often times what they'll do is
they'll be controlling
they'll be controlling and they'll be
like [ __ ] let me check your phone don't
be talking to all the [ __ ]
they'll be hyper jealous
okay dudes will be putting in way too
much effort to fright women after a year
in because they realize they've gotten
into the trap and the guys that aren't
doing much will just drop like flies
when you've given them a challenge this
is the only way to weed out the guys who
are serious and the guys that are just
trying to play with you keep your
standards up and that's right keep your
standard up and you'll end up alone like
me
lonely [ __ ] or maybe she's not we i
mean that's the stuff we just say you
know maybe she has a husband who knows i
don't know
today congratulations lady yeah this
whole idea of romanticizing men in other
countries like i'm not i'm not confident
that you travel much because if you ask
women who are living in latin america
they'll tell you the men over there
cheat all the time they're extreme
misogynists
complain about them all the time right
go to the middle east you think all
those women are saying the men over
there are the best go to europe see how
they say about the men
come on okay so you're over here
romanticizing men and saying oh my god
the women there are having so much
better the women over there like who you
[ __ ] talking to
who are you talking to who are you
talking about who who
are you talking to
we struggling out here what you talking
about
right so you have to understand every
every every area comes with the sound of
problems you out here getting brazen on
on [ __ ] tick tock talking [ __ ] about
men locally go over some of these saudi
go to saudi arabia and be talk crazy
about the men over there see what
happens when you get slapped up by your
boy huh you think you just talk about
saudi man however you want while you're
living over there
and nobody's gonna do [ __ ] the freedoms
that you get to enjoy in a western
country with all these [ __ ] boys who let
you talk crazy you may not be able to
talk like that everywhere you go
you know what's funny the funny thing is
that it's funny that she's talking about
man being spoiled
and the only reason why she's talking
like that is because she's spoiled
that's facts
a lot of the issues that we have today
in regards to non-commitment or people
being lucy goosey is because the fact
that we've made dating such a accessible
accessible
we've made it such a
window shopping experience where you can
go in the shop and pick out whatever you
want so we got online dating where we
can browse with people it's not just men
women too women are constantly like
everybody has that fear of missing out
where they got a partner they kind of
like but they're like i wanted more
excitement i wanted more of that right
so people go on to the next thing okay
and there's an issue where
it's like folks always want more or they
want something better or they think
they've got some that's more attack
that's out there a lot too but anyways
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below